this is one of those morning's where you
wake up you see a text from your friend
that says hey you want me to come over a
little later than plans you can do a
video and that Avengers end game trailer
and I'm like the what now so yeah we
have a new trailer - Avengers end game
which indeed does feel like the end game
but a little about the trailer is how
vague it is we've reached the point
where it's like the IP itself the
Avengers name is gonna sell it how many
people watched Avengers infinity war
whether they're just not curious as to
how they get the folks back the team
now most we're gonna watch it and they
know that and I love that because now we
have a trailer that just it gives the
tone it kind of goes back to the
beginning of it all it's all black and
white you see when Iron Man started
Captain America Thor and then it's still
black and white but then you see the red
Red's the only color you see which of
course illustrates the tragedy and the
blood pay I mean that was just a dark
time I watched Avengers infinity war
just the other day I like it more and
more every time I say it cuz I was
really taken in the fact it's like this
is this generation star wars in fact
this movie is this generations Empire
Strikes Back took us more than two
movies to get there took us about
nineteen doesn't change the fact that
infinity war man they had a bad day they
lost you see Hawkeye with his daughter
he looks really happy then you see him
like that so you know she vaporized girl
turned to ash she's he Captain American
whose trailers like everyone's been told
to move on and they should but not us no
we need to make this right which also do
you see no Thanos in this trailer which
is again a thing I love about this
trailers the natural course of thought
at least my thought process like oh I
got to go after Thanos and take him down
but that doesn't necessarily get
everyone back what's the goal here take
out Thanos for a revenge or get everyone
back are they the same or they to
completely compartmentalize separate
things either gonna get everyone back
then show up to Thanos his mancave farm
and pull a Travolta from swordfish too
bad you got to die
I'm the only person in the last decade
to referenced swordfish I don't know how
I feel about it I got Van Damme Street
Fighter references for days though this
trailer hits on the concept of the
tragedy that ever like will half the
people disappeared and that's half the
people and living with life forms in the
universe not just the motive dust
suspended in a sunbeam doing that I feel
like this isn't going to be as
action-packed as Avengers endgame at
least from this trailer and the concept
of just what we got to get everyone back
a stano's a part of killing him getting
them back right I don't know does even
have the gauntlet does it work the same
we're not trying to stop him we're just
gonna show up in its farm and beat his
ass to death if I'm looking at this
trailer and sizing it up with Avengers
infinity where I feel like infinity war
is like Kill Bill Vol 1 this might be
like Kill Bill Vol 2 first one was more
action-packed second one not as much but
still important together they make one
huge saga one very fulfilling saga will
in Kill Bill revenge tale one of the
best ever
this is a gooey gushy comic book nerd
Ness and who knows Stannis might be a
huge part of this movie I don't think
he's gonna be as big as he was in
Avengers infinity war Pictures infinity
war was his movie the end of Infinity
Ward says Thanos will return usually the
blank will return is reserved for the
heroes and at the end of Avengers
infinity war it absolutely definitely
was at the end of the trailer you see
them walking in these white suits which
is like I recognize those white suits I
think it's from Marvel heroes too
tragically canceled Marvel heroes
I loved Midtown mondays man that's how I
spent my Monday but I believe it's
Marvel heroes I remembered Gamora
wearing a suit like I don't know if it's
supposed to be the same either case she
ain't gonna wear him now too soon
because in the end Avengers end games I
love this trailer I love how this
trailer took it back to the beginning we
saw how they started and now where
they've ended up Thank You Avengers end
game trailer and Marvel Studios for not
spoiling thanks for keeping it
vague well you know we're gonna watch it
generally I don't know the plot of this
movie other than they want to get people
back and I figured that would be the
case so even after two trailers going
into this movie blind and I love that
feeling first of the New Avengers
endgame trailer have you seen it why did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]